hey everyone it's Mike from orderflows
and I'm shooting this quick video
because I want to tell you about the
orderflows unlocked which is an advanced
trade setup encyclopedia now we know
that in the world of trading knowledge
isn't just power basically it's what
gives you your Edge in the market and
it's from your Edge is where your
profits come from right you need an edge
to be successful in the market so
welcome to the orderflows unlocked
Advanced trade encyclopedia which is a
new guide to mastering the markets
through institutional order flow
analysis now let me ask you right we
we're all familiar with the footprint
chart right but do you really know and
understand what you're looking at you
know what if you could see beyond the
surface of just the numbers and actually
decode the actual mechanisms that are
driving Price Right which is the order
flow in the market and that's exactly
what order flows unlocked does you know
there are 91 new orderflow trading
setups that are extracted directly from
Market actions now you know in the past
I've released uh the last year the trade
encyclopedia and really what orderflows
unlocked is is it takes it to another
level now you know with most orderflow
software you know I was the one that
revolutionized orderflow software and I
have a lot of tools in here accumulation
distribution align POC uh Delta
breakouts Divergence Delta tails what I
do is I explain each one of these to you
first and then I take it a step further
and I show you how to combine the
different aspects of order flow into a
trade setup because you know there are
some aspects of order flow that are good
for reversals there are some that are
good for momentum right there are good
some that are good for um support and
resistance there are some that that's
good for um you know just basic
orderflow uh continuation patterns Etc
but really the area that I found that
most Trad your struggle is sort of
trying to put the pieces together right
you know sometimes they they send me a
chart they're saying I I can't figure
this out you know because maybe they're
looking at something that's momentum
based in a reversal
environment okay so that's why I
I handpicked these 91
setups that I explain in detail I show
you with chart examples and I show you
how to see them because you know at the
end of the day what you want to be able
to do is understand what you're looking
at in the market right so for example
right from say uh stacked imbalances how
you want to use it with other aspects of
order flow okay what about resting
liquidity what other pieces of the order
flow do you want to add with resting
liquidity what about something as simple
as you know momentum in the market what
other pieces of order flow work great
with momentum okay so imagine knowing
which combination of specific orderflow
data points because at the end of the
day that is what order flow is that's
what this the footprint you know a lot
of people get confused with the
footprint oh there's a lot of numbers I
don't know to make of it but it's just
data right and you can take that data
and you
can use it interpret it and make good
trading decisions
so what we do in the order flows
unlocked is we show you how to interpret
these sing signals layer them
effectively with each other and find
trades in the market okay think of it as
like having a road map in the footprint
chart where others just see random
patterns
okay and that's really what the whole
order flows unlocked Advanced trade
encyclopedia is about right it's about
helping you see what's taking place in
the market you know this just isn't any
trading guide it's a deep dive into
basically you know the the DNA of Market
movements what's causing it what is
taking place it provides you with
insights that basically remain invisible
to most other Traders and by
understanding and leveraging the order
flow you're not just say following
Trends you know you're predicting them
you're not just about um you know
getting in after a market moves it's
about seeing how the market is moving
right now and getting in all right so
you know whether you're a seasoned
orderflow Trader or you know maybe
you're you're sort of a newcomer and you
know you want to get started on the
right foot with orderflow I think
orderflow is unlocked is your gateway to
trading with Clarity and becoming a
better Trader because at the end of the
day that's really what you want to do is
because you want to improve as a Trader
so if you're ready to you know unlock
really the pow power of orderflow right
the analysis that goes into it then you
know I think you really need to get
order flows unlocked because it's going
to basically help you see the market as
you've never seen it before so to get
started click on the link below and I'll
see you guys on the inside